all right six vacancies still exist no
coaches hired yet urban meyer
gets the jaguars job if he wants it
chris that's been out there for so long
the jaguars have done nothing to push
back they met with him on friday he's
calling around to get staff lined up
general manager candidates etc the
question is does he want it the other
question is do they want to give him the
big mammoo that he's looking for of
course that doesn't get discussed all
that openly but that's part of it as
well there could be a seventh vacancy
espn reported yesterday that jeffrey
lurie the owner of the eagles still may
fire doug peterson who took the team to
the playoffs three straight years and
won a super bowl but what are you doing
for me right now it's not what have you
done for me lately what are you doing
for me right now you're not winning and
you don't have a vision for the team and
i confirmed all of this yesterday eagles
officially have no comment but i
confirmed all of it the conversations
continue chris and if jeffrey lurie
doesn't like what he hears from doug
peterson about his vision for the team
there will be seven vacancies and uh
then the question becomes does one of
these other teams say hey doug peterson
super bowl winning coach i'm gonna
snatch him up yeah i mean i mean i think
he would definitely be in play if he
does get on the market here you know
it's crazy that we're having this
conversation but there's obviously
something really wrong there in
philadelphia there really is i mean
because you're right listen i don't
think jeffrey lurie is a guy that's just
like
you know off the hinge owner who's gonna
just do crazy crap he doesn't come off
that way he's never been like that or
shown me the evidence of that since he's
owned the philadelphia eagles so
there must be something there and you
know listen mike you know i know people
around the nfl too yeah from what i've
been told he is not out of the woods by
any stretch of the imagination that it's
still very much on the table that he
could be fired and yeah there is
again i don't know what exactly it is
but there is obviously a concern with
doug peterson and whether it's the
vision for his team the way he handled
that situation towards the end of the
year either way something's not lining
up to where they're thinking about
making a change
and i think what has to make it so
distressing for jeffrey lurie is you're
coming off of a period of time
where you thought you had it all figured
out and you wouldn't have to worry about
finding a new coach thinking about
finding a new general manager thinking
about finding a new anything for years
to come here we are we are reaching
potential patriot level we'll be
relevant we'll contend we'll be in the
playoffs and maybe we'll have another
super bowl or two or three who knows to
have it disintegrate that fast to the
point where your faith is shaken in
things that you thought were settled i
think that's what makes it even harder
and credit to jeffrey lurie for being
willing to look at this with a critical
eye and ask tough questions and not just
say maybe it was an aberration we'll
give it one more spin
and see what happens maybe there's no
need for one more spin maybe the magic
is gone and
uh look here's the difference chris if
mike thomas would get fired today by the
steelers he'd have a job with someone
else tomorrow if doug peterson gets
fired today by the eagles he doesn't
have a job tomorrow
and he may not get one of the other ones
i think they at least at a minimum will
have to do their work to understand
exactly what the hell happened in
philadelphia this year sure to get the
eagles to fire him i i think you're
right there's no doubt you know and and
uh yeah i i i agree with everything you
said there
i mean i think you're right mike tomlin
gets fired people are gonna break down
doors to get him in the in the room to
be the head coach doug peterson
you know yes there's going to be
certainly interest in everything that
way but you know he's supposed to be an
offensive genius and those type of
things the offense has not been anything
special the last few years that's
certainly not going to help them and
then yeah when there's just just this
much talk you know like the old phrase
where there's smoke there's fire there's
just there's got to be something there
you're right that's going to make teams
hesitate call what's going on let me
investigate this what happened here
and you know i i because i just i don't
think howie roseman or or jeffrey luery
are the type of guy that want to do this
i i don't think they are i don't think
that that is i think there's obviously
an issue here that's that's concerning
to them
no smoke or fire as it relates to
chief's offensive coordinator eric b
enemy we entered the process assuming
that his ship was going to come in this
time around that someone would hire him
and there's a sense now he is going to
get passed over again he's privately
saying he's going to stay in kansas city
and wait for the best possible job to
come from the perfect job to come open
meanwhile there's a log jam that's being
created because andy reid wants to pivot
to mike kafka as offensive coordinator
you know they went from doug peterson he
gets a head coaching job matt nagy he
gets a head coaching job eric banami
he's stalled and spins his spot for
three years chris and it may be four
years i i mean that would be the shock
of the the coaching hire cycle the fact
of eric the enemy the guy who's
been the right-hand man or right there
involved in orchestrating the best
offense we've seen in football the last
three years
uh uh that would i think shine a light
on this whole situation again to another
degree you know i i don't even
understand how that happens at this
point with everybody trying to find the
young coordinator qb guru
we have a guy with the top offense in
football
who helped you know bring along the best
quarterback in the game right now the
biggest star in our game and he's not
doesn't sound like he's gonna get
offered like i mean there's just nothing
it's there's nothing even close it
doesn't even sound like oh it's between
the enemy and this guy or we really want
to hide like there's none of those
rumors you talk to anybody i don't hear
any of that so that's just that's
amazing to me i'm shocked by that
five teams interviewed him the texans
didn't and the fact that they didn't has
contributed to this rank how does that
happen
listen how do you not interview him just
to tell your quarterback hey we
interviewed the guy the one guy you told
us to do how does that happen that is
like crazy stupid
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports